hat and scarf built into one sign us up
knitted hoods or as the fashion set dubb
them B clavas are Fashion's favorite
accessory for winter again they're the
one accessory we're seeing all over
Instagram feeds this winter they've also
found a place on the catwalks of major
designers last year for timn winter 2022
mimu styled their Woolen helmets with
puffer jackets snow boots and
unsuspectingly party dresses Simone Rosa
did the same contrasting their signature
girlish frogs with knitted headwear and
Kate took their classic cashmere
approach to the design and this year
thanks to solded Fashion Week street
style inspo they're all over the High
Street is this a trend you'll jump on